begin by thanking the jets and panthers
for not doing it on saturday not doing
it on easter sunday like the eagles in
washington once did with donna mcnabb
back in 2010 disrupting an otherwise
peaceful and relaxing late afternoon
wait until monday when we're all fully
engaged and we're ready to give our hot
takes so thank you for being judicious
about the news flow and the news came
late yesterday afternoon darnold to the
carolina panthers for a smattering of
draft picks nothing close to the three
second round picks the jets gave the
colts when they flip-flop six and three
in 2018 so clearly the investment did
not pan out the way the jets had hoped
but they turn
a guy that they otherwise were done with
into something they get a second round
pick in 2022 which isn't bad and they
move forward clearly with a quarterback
in the second overall spot many believe
it will be oh yeah wilson what was your
initial reaction when you saw the news
well i mean not surprised either i mean
yeah i mean we we talked about all this
stuff for the last month you know i
don't want to sit here and like first
off i think you know with matt rule joe
douglas like you know i i think at that
time they weren't sure how things were
going to play out so i don't think
they're totally lying to us but yes like
you like me i mean we saw it on the
horizon i mean
and especially i think once we saw the
zack wilson workout i think that's when
you just went okay wait all right that
was special i know it's just a workout
but we haven't seen a lot of workouts
that it looked like that so uh
not surprised i guess i'm surprised that
it happened yesterday i wasn't expecting
it kind of came out of nowhere but
really thought something like this would
go down and good trade for both sides
really the way i look at it because you
know i love zach wilson
well and for sam darnold the jury's
still out on what he's going to be
but
i said this yesterday afternoon as we
were reacting in real time to what had
transpired
i tend to believe that
if a quarterback is going to become a
true
shortlist franchise quarterback he
declares it early we see something in
the first three seasons that makes us
say there it is wait there's that thing
there's that moment there's that special
skill that no one else in the world
possesses that he's going to demonstrate
from time to time and all due respect to
sam darnold chris there's been nothing
in his first three years that has caused
us to say holy crap or another
four-letter word that we can't say on
peacock although i'm still confused
about that but regardless sure or
irregardless as they may say the the
the reality is the jets came to the
conclusion the jets who know them better
than anyone after three years came to
the conclusion it's time to move on and
part of that is
we got
sam dardle in the hand
we got the potential of zach wilson in
the bush
where we're we think that wilson is
going to give us the moments we never
got from darnold i think that's it i
don't neces i don't think it's
necessarily like an indictment on sam
darnold like oh man you can't play it
didn't work here with the jets you're
out of here you know we're shipping you
out the first trade offer we get right
no i still i still think there was a lot
of belief in that building i do as far
as like what he could be and the fact
that he had you know got the the short
straw or the short stick whatever you
want to say as far as support around him
help you know it was the last regime who
made that trade you know like you said
to go up from six to three now it's a
new regime trying to claim clean things
up certainly you know yes sam donald
like we've always been talking about it
hasn't been great we know that but i
mean how good can it be i mean how good
can it really be like with the cast of
characters that have been around him
it's just not possible to really succeed
yeah okay maybe mahomes and aaron
rodgers can make it work and look better
but it's like a very very short list of
people that could have done anything
with that jets football team
to to make us feel like oh wow they're
here they've arrived they did him an
injustice they never really got you know
the support around him to let him get
going as a football player and even
establish himself to leave her or even
have enough talent around him to give
the moments that you're talking about
you know that that's what i think is the
big thing with sam darnold i will not be
shocked if he goes down to carolina and
wins football games and ends up having a
real good career down there uh in a
place that you know i think really suits
him as far as talent and the way the
system is run down there in carolina
was he good enough over the past three
years to justify being the third overall
pick in the draft regardless of the
supporting cast around well no probably
not no no i mean okay yeah he wasn't the
number three pick of the draft he was
not that's a that's a fair question or a
fair way to say it certainly but you
know again you say it all the time we
know that the draft is a crap shoot he
was a guy that had a lot of hype coming
out you know
from usc he had that great rose bowl
game against penn state where after that
you couldn't tell the world he wasn't
the greatest thing since sliced bread
it's it's a lot like the trevor lawrence
conversation we're having this year
you're not allowed to say he's not the
greatest quarterback ever it was the
same way that year with him and how
remember how everybody was shocked like
what the browns are gonna take baker
mayfield they're not gonna take sam
darnold who everybody was just saying
was the best and i have the highest qb
grade in the history of scouting on this
guy and all that stuff so
no he did not live up to expectations
but i also will say he got no help
or no nudge to to really be able to
deliver on those expectations either i
mean come on those receivers this year
gee williker's batman they were pitiful
when you think back to the 2017 season
and that was the first year we were
working together on this program darnold
was the guy wired a wire who was
regarded as the top quarterback prospect
yeah in the ensuing draft and i have a
vivid recollection of someone on this
show constantly referring to him as sam
darno i can't remember whether it was
the french he was a little french back
then
but but
i i
it's it's i think
coincidental yeah and important that the
darnold trade happened on monday because
over the weekend and we really have
reached the low water mark between free
agency and the draft when things like
this become news
there's someone with the athletic who
who wrote an article that caught some
traction that zach wilson wait for it
yeah is a boom or bust prospect whoa
well no no crap
they all are and i think the only reason
it created headlines is because
no one else
generally speaking will come out and say
there's a chance all these quarterbacks
that are getting all this publicity and
the run-up to the draft aren't going to
be any good some of them won't be
very good we just don't know at this
point so we don't talk about i think
there's two reasons we don't talk about
it and i say we i mean everyone in media
we know that
this is all about selling hope
to the fan bases
whose teams select these players so it's
better to view the glass as half full
it's kind of evolved that way over time
when in rome hype up the draft picks and
also if people are too candid about you
know if mel kiper on his conference
calls that he does i don't know once a
week once every other week and all the
other draft experts are saying well you
know there's a chance that
half these guys are going to stink the
next question is well which ones are
going to stick well we don't know well
why are we listening to you then and and
so it's all positive but when we look
back
the history is strewn with with guys who
work out look at 28 look at 2018.
baker mayfield we still don't know for
sure sam darnold trending bust josh
rosen what the hell happened to him josh
allen superstar lamar jackson superstar
five guys taking in round one two
superstars yeah and three other guys
where one we know
now who knows what's gonna happen with
him maybe he gets lucky in san francisco
maybe mac jones or whoever's gonna be
picked gets injured and he works his way
up is a better backup than than the guys
they've had behind jimmy garoppolo but
josh rosen's off the radar screen and
now sam darnold is relegated to carolina
so the thing to remember is as we get
ready for the draft which is three weeks
and two days away
there's no guarantee that any of these
guys are going to be great and chances
are half of them won't be even at the
quarterback position which has gotten
better in recent years there's still a
50 50 shot that guy that you think is
going to save your franchise isn't as
the jets found out in giving up on sam
darnold yeah well hey listen first round
first round picks it's all about elite
traits right so that can lend to at
times being bust or a player not turning
out the way you want them because hey
you saw something on film where you went
wow this is really special okay maybe
this guy's got some other areas he's got
to clean up but this one area is special
and if we can build on that it could be
something and of course yes people do
miss and do those type of things and
miss evaluate or don't do the right
thing to support the player to really
get the the the the the draft pick you
know the jump off
that's the big thing and again that's
what i'll go back to with sam darnold
and where he was done wrong from the
get-go there with the new york jets you
know and you talk about other
quarterbacks right you know i mean the
ones that have succeeded for the most
part have had talent around them from
the get-go to kind of get going on the
right foot gain confidence get the team
to get confidence in you wow we've won
games oh this guy's got the it factor
that's what comes next and now it's oh
look he's the man he's a franchise
quarterback
and so that has to be part of the team
to help the quarterback reach that
pinnacle spot to be that guy and that's
where the jets never helped sam darnold
and you're right it is a crap crap shoe
we don't know i mean we don't know about
trevor lawrence or zack wilson but we
see enough really really high level
stuff to go oh man i mean if they just
work hard and do things the right way
man they're gonna be able to do some
special special things and i think
that's ultimately what the jets looked
at i think the jets have had their eye
on zach wilson throughout the whole year
and then of course now it's all the
the coaches get to evaluate when they
come in they get to see it and then you
get to go to a pro day and he does
something like that
that puts you in a spot where you go wow
i'm really excited i gotta stamp as joe
douglas or a chance to put a stamp on
the franchise the way i want it and
build this team the way i really see fit
not the way the last regime did with sam
darnold in that trade and i think that's
probably what excites the jets and it
should excite the jet fans too
and look i i'm not defending the jets
here because frankly based upon their
performance over the past oh i don't
know 50 years there's no sense in trying
to defend them but
but
if you've got it
it's obvious the moment that tyrod
taylor has his unfortunate run-in with
dr needle last year yeah and justin
herbert is literally told five minutes
literally before the game grab your
helmet and play
and
and it's like
holy crap this kid can play
we never had that from sam darnold never
had that at some point when you do have
the elite traits it transcends the crap
that's around you not that there was
crap around justin herbert with the
chargers but you get my point i got you
at some level
the quarterback is so good yeah that he
elevates the guys around him i i guess
and arnold was never that no he was
never that you're right there there is
even even if they can't elevate and you
just see you go whoa there's something
about that guy herbert even that first
game when we watched him it was wasn't
that he blew our doors off game one but
you looked at it and you went man he's
big whoa he's fast and man he's got a
really unbelievable arm and seems to
throw it very easily 40 yards down the
field six feet off the ground you know
you're right there was those things that
jumped off mike it's the big reason i
pushed back against sam darnold the
first time around i mean when he got
drafted because you're you never saw
that on film in college you never saw a
guy that was just throwing lasers all
over the field you saw a guy that was a
good player had a good arm had quick
feet and you know for the college level
was a great scrambler so he could play
backyard football and it was fun to
watch and you just felt like man usc is
never out of it with sam darnold but
that doesn't always translate to the nfl
it's a different game and yes that's
where sam darnold is he gonna be a
superstar i would say no i don't see
superstar in him like you're saying and
that's that's where the jets mess that
up mike mckag mcagnen and company as far
as taking them in the top five i don't
see that either but still
think you put them on a good football
team and you give them weapons like dj
moore and robbie anderson and christian
mccaffrey and ian thomas at tight end
and those type of things i go oh no you
can win football games with sam darnold
you can do that and and i think that's
you know realistically the realistically
the way i i view them excuse me could
have had josh allen instead that year
didn't even have to trade up from six to
three and could have had josh no but his
completion percentage mike his
completion percentage oh my gosh mike
his completion percentage he didn't get
to throw screens and he threw played in
a blizzard and had nobody blocking and
didn't have one talented receiver but it
was all josh allen's fault it was nobody
else basically
basically allen would have been the same
with the jets as he was in wyoming
no i'm not i'm not i think josh allen
would have had more of those moments
of like you were saying about justin
herbert where things wouldn't i don't
know if it would have mattered a whole
lot of the win-loss column but i think
josh allen like we've seen over the last
three years even when it wasn't pretty
he would do some stuff and we go damn
that was whoa that was good whoa holy
cow what a throw what a run i mean he
did stuff like that to your point that
opened our eyes and then what did
buffalo do they started getting talent
around them and all of a sudden explode
so we'll see maybe it does explode from
sam darnold but he certainly doesn't
have josh allen's talent which we know
is superstar special
and that gets back to my original point
we haven't seen anything from darnold
that would make us say holy crap like we
have from josh allen yeah i think right
hey there there are interesting
exercises in alternate history that we
could engage in i've said for years what
if the bengals had ended up with
achilles smith and the eagles head or
donovan and eagles had ended up with a
kelly smith is is does andy reid turn
achilles smith into something and does
starting his career with the bengals
caused donovan mcnabb to wash out of the
nfl as quickly as smith did those are
things we'll never know but obviously
that first organization you end up with
what they do to help and support you or
otherwise and coach you yeah and get the
best out of you right that has a huge
impact on whether or not you fulfill
that promise that you have as a top 10
pick now i thought the sweet spot for
the jets when it came to trading sam
darnold would be to wait until after
round one
see who's left after the music stops on
the top quarterbacks
panthers
broncos
other teams possibly and then you try to
trade sam darnold thinking back to two
years ago when the cardinals waited
until after round one you have about 18
hours before the start of round two they
traded josh rosen after picking kyler
murray i thought maybe the jets would
take zach wilson wait to trade sam
darnold but
i get the impression chris
when you consider what the jets picked
up here
and they got a second round pick next
year a fourth round pick next year a
sixth round pick this year
there's a good chance that the panthers
one of the candidates to be that team
between round one and round two weren't
going to be waiting around and would
have addressed their needs somewhere
else and i feel like the jets just had
to do it now yeah had to make it happen
now because there's no guarantee that
package was going to be there later and
i think they benefited from that urgency
that the panthers may have we're going
to talk more about the panthers side of
it but they've obviously been trying to
upgrade of course right and and they've
had the door slammed in their face at
every turn yeah so maybe the jets were
able to get more now than they would
have gotten later for sam darnold right
well i mean you know maybe you're right
i mean we know they were in the matthew
stafford conversation we know they want
desean watson that door is closed you
know we've heard them rumored with teams
in the draft everything like that mike i
think it comes down to like something
kind of you just said there at the end
where they probably wanted to go
you know as far as the jets are
concerned
wait there's only a few teams left that
really need quarterbacks and as we sit
here right now it's really only two i
know we know you know like we talked
about yesterday maybe seattle something
can happen there but as it stands right
now this second
it was carolina and denver
it was one of those two teams so i i
would bet the jets probably looked at it
a little bit to go wait like wait if
they fill one of those holes at
quarterback or whatever now we're down
to one team and that's it or then we
might have to wait to the draft and i i
would think that the panthers you know
from their standpoint mike they they
want to get their team figured out here
they want to figure out how they're
going to orchestrate the draft you know
okay wait we got this quarterback let's
start to think about how we can run our
offense do those type of things and
here's the big thing
to me that like i just i think we're all
missing
panthers didn't want to take a
quarterback at eight they didn't so they
the way they looked at it right now and
they went okay wait it seems like one
two three is gonna be quarterback we
don't like four or five at number eight
so
that that that to me is what they came
to the determination of so now they can
move on to how they want to adjust their
draft and they're off the quarterback
conversation and how we gonna finagle to
maybe move up in the draft to figure
this out or all those type of things now
they don't have to worry about it now
they can go wait we can pick whatever we
need at number eight or if somebody
wants to trade up to number eight to
maybe get one of these quarterbacks
maybe we could trade down do something
like that but i do find that to be the
interesting angle too that the panthers
kind of threw in the towel with the
quarterbacks in the draft and said the
hell with it we're going sam darnold and
we're moving on
well there was a report or a suggestion
or whatever we want to call it recently
from mike tannenbaum the former gm of
the jets and he was an executive with
the dolphins that
that the panthers were looking into the
three spot as well when the 49ers made
that jump from 12 all the way up to
three making it clear they were taking a
quarterback and i think if you're
sitting at eight
and as the boards begin to shift and
harden
you realize
quarterback at one quarterback at two
quarterback at three right maybe
quarterback at four
maybe quarterback at five if the bengals
slide down and the broncos jump up and
you know we have to assume that the
panthers have had all relevant
conversations and considered all
potential permutations to try to get
justin fields or trey lance assuming
those are the two guys who are going to
be left and as you said
you just you don't
maybe they would have been interested in
those guys that they had landed at eight
but you don't want to give up on top of
eight
to get those guys whatever it is you'd
have to give up to move up to four or
five so we're gonna go the sam donald
route instead and the the jets benefit
because
i i i never got the impression the
broncos were all that interested in
darnold as a potential upgrade over drew
locke right
and
where else
does donald go once the 49ers slam the
door on the possibility yeah then
carolina
and you know carolina was not a team
that we had high on the list of
potential sam darnold destination so the
jets i think got a little bit lucky here
and i think the jets made their move now
because they recognize there's a damn
good chance they weren't going to get
something like right
when april 27 28 29 rolls around and the
draft gets going and
teams start making other moves and teams
maybe address needs between now and then
so i think the jets did what they had to
do knowing that they were going
quarterback knowing that that's right
they weren't going to keep darling
around and the other angle here too
we've got the fifth year option that the
panthers will now pick up on sam darnold
at 18.8 million for the first time that
option is fully guaranteed at exercise
so
the jets had to make this move before
may 3.
they had to do it otherwise what they
were going to be trading was one year
with sam darnold at roughly 4 million
no guarantee that you could keep them
around for a second here so what value
are you getting if you're the panthers
or someone else if you wait too long to
do it so the jets had to get it done
they had to make a decision as to which
guy they were going to keep they
couldn't keep both
zach wilson or whoever they take it
number two that's right so they did what
they had to do and they got what they
got and i think they got a better deal
now than they would have gotten later
period i think there's i think you're
right i mean yeah i mean you just don't
know how it's going to shake out and
they don't want to be there like in this
situation you're talking about in may or
now hey wait we've got a new quarterback
of our team but we're spending all our
time talking about the quarterback we
don't want and why what are we going to
do with him and how are we going to
split rip reps during you know otas and
doing all those things it works for both
sides carolina now gets their
quarterback and they can start feeding
him offense and playbook and pages
because you know
just to get the head start there and i
don't know if we're going to have
on-field work at any point or not but
i'm guessing coaches i know coaches
they're they're hoping and expecting
that at some point after the draft
they're going to be able to get on the
field practice do those things and you
know that of course you want to have
that situation settled there too just so
sam darnold can get in the huddle and
you know seamlessly call plays and not
being you know going through the the
learning of all that on the fly after
the draft so i think uh it makes sense
from both sides mike i really do
and i i think he really fits with what
carolina wants to do on the offensive
side of the ball
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports